have the thing poster I don't know if
you have it on camera but he's got the
poster from the movie The Thing yes and
John Carpenters John Carpenter's The
Thing which is still was one of the most
shockingly great movies oh man and that
poster was done overnight by Drew
strewson that piece of art right there
overnight he did in 24 hours because
they needed it in 24 hours and he had to
come up with a concept do this do that
and execute on it and it's one of the
most brilliant posters it is because
it's so ambiguous but like dark yes well
I've also noticed notice that one hand
is flexed like this
and one hand is reaching for you it's
sort of it sort of suggests that the
thing doesn't know it's the thing at
that moment just like in the movie that
the copies you you get the sense that
the copies of the people are not aware
that they're copies until a mouth sprigs
out of their chest you know they're like
that's true so one hand is like a victim
one hand is reaching for you yeah I
never noticed that and I I asked Drew
I'm like why did you do that it's like I
don't know just felt right he didn't
have time to think
yeah well no I've I've known him
personally through Frank darabon Drew
actually did a poster for Being Human as
a favor to me and you learned that for a
couple years yeah uh yeah I was that
that being him was uh went four years
and Drew this is kind of funny
this is where I I would only say this on
the Michael Rosenbaum podcast but since
we're talking like about you know we say
people say things on this that they just
should never say so I think people just
open up and uh you know whatever so so
here's something that has never been
publicly told
um
sci-fi at the time was trying to do a
bunch of different stuff
Being Human was coming out with our
third third season and the material was
really strong I felt like we didn't have
as strong a second season but our third
season was really funny and really
strong and really great
and all of our publicity budget was
siphoned over to a new project they were
doing so there was no publicity no
publicity so I I said to the cast I'm
like guys I can get Drew to do this he
offered to do it for a fraction he says
he says you got to pay me something
because come on I gotta keep the lights
on but I'll not charge you anything near
what I charge for a poster for to paint
a Being Human poster and he'd already
done a piece of art for me for free that
was being human just for out of the
goodness of his heart I said could you
do a full poster he's like that he's
like you have to understand the
commitment
let me guess he gave you a discount I'm
guessing ten thousand uh it was a little
bit more than ten thousand it was a lot
less than thirty thousand 25 000. it was
twenty twenty thousand did you asked the
cast members to chip in no no what I did
was this I said cast members if I gave
you a bunch of juicers and posters would
you sign them and they said yes I'm like
great I'll sell those to make the money
back and that way we get we get a
publicity piece for our season three and
Drew who usually charges astronomical
prices way way way higher than that I
said would you do this and he said
yeah okay I'll do it for that so give me
the sweetheart price you know and then
spent weeks weeks doing this was it
great I loved it loved it now did you
get your money back oh yes so you sold
them at cons yeah and people bought them
how many did you have oh I can't
remember I have a few left yeah like 80
bucks each 80 bucks that's it so you
just make copies Yeah well yeah I made
these uh sort of prints and really high
quality prints and the cast signed all
of them and I still sell these on Etsy
and stuff so I have some left so you're
the one who paid all of it I paid the
twenty thousand yeah and so have you
made your money back yeah you have yeah
yeah that's ballsy and cool yeah well I
had to come up with something I'm like
where's not publicizing what's so far
our best season did the uh publicist or
publicity Department really like it and
use it yeah they did a little bit but
they were also they didn't use it as
much as I'd like because I think they
were a little embarrassed that the actor
is paying his own money yeah because you
guys aren't doing dude so I
remember going into a meeting with
sci-fi and we presented the poster and
it was gorgeous it was it was
legitimately gorgeous and I remember the
execs at sci-fi they're like well you
have to understand Sam I just wanna we
wanna open up
the possibility that we use this photo
shoot that we did for season three that
we were really proud of we're really
proud of these photos and I'm like these
photos right here they're like yeah
well I put together that shoot too guys
because I did I organized a photo shoot
because we didn't even have so much as a
photo shoot they really didn't they
didn't do anything so I pointed again
like you like those photos they're like
yeah and I'm like well I did that that
was something I organized and so I'm
like so this poster you understand like
see these from like and I pulled over
open a few photos for them like see
these photos interesting how they're in
the same position as in the poster this
is reference for the poster guys I put
together a photo shoot that doubled as
reference to give to Drew so he could
make the poster so they are embarrassed
again
probably not the best move in my place
because that were they I said it with a
smile all right yeah by the way I gotta
ask It's A Rosenbaum question